hi my name is Betsy Bradley and I'm the
faculty director of the global health
Leadership Institute at Yale today I'm
joined by David Berg who is a clinical
professor in psychiatry at the Yale
School of Medicine and an organizational
psychologist and today we're here to
talk about leadership you know everybody
and David you know everybody is studying
leadership everybody talks about it
so it's one of the fundamental things if
you've got a new job you need to learn
how to be a leader and have those
leadership skills so I wanted to start
us with what do you think are the most
common misunderstandings about
leadership well I'd say there's probably
three so the first one is that
leadership is a trait of a person that
one is either born with or that one has
as a characteristic of self from growing
up etc and I I don't think it's actually
a trait I don't think it's something
that in here is in a person I think as
we'll talk about I'm sure I think it's a
function in an organization or a social
setting
so one misunderstanding is that people
have it or can be given it it's a trait
the second thing I would say is that
only one person does it so when we talk
about leadership we tend to use words
like leaders that suggest that
leadership is done by one person I think
that's the second thing I don't I don't
believe it's ever done in a social
system by one person and the third thing
I would say is that there's only one way
to do it you there's just too much
diversity of people in leadership roles
in the way in which people in those
roles are successful in different kinds
of settings and different kinds of
organizations to believe that there's
only one right way to do leadership and
yet we tend to perpetuate the belief by
and theories that there's one way to do
it right even contingency theories will
say under these circumstances do it one
particular way I think it's over
emphasized the one-wayness do you mind
just talking a little bit about what do
you mean when you say contingency theory
so there are lots of different phases in
the evolution of leadership theory and
one of those was called contingency
theory which said that the behavior
action of someone in a leadership role
depends on the circumstances the
circumstances of the task or the job
being done the circumstances of the
people being worked with those kinds of
things so I want to ask you about
business schools and management schools
because I think they grew out of
thinking there was one way you just need
to take these courses and you will be a
leader you'll be successful and I'm
wondering that still seems to be around
and what do you think of that and how do
you think we ought to be thinking about
developing the skill of somebody to lead
well so I think it's right I think I
think most education in the area of
leadership is based on the assumption
that leadership is something in a person
that you can develop or teach or train
and while I don't think that's a hundred
percent wrong I think what it misses is
the fact that leadership I believe is
fundamentally a relational concept that
is it comes into being when there's a
relationship without a relationship
there is no leadership so you as faculty
director of things when you're at home
sitting in your dining room by yourself
you are not a leader you can't be and if
you're thinking of yourself as a leader
you're thinking of yourself in one or
more different relational context
because that's what creates leadership
it is a function for a social system the
smallest social system being two people
but usually it's about a faculty group
or about an organization and the
leadership function comes into being
when that when one or more different
kinds of
ships exist so I would say we're going
to be more successful at teaching people
in various professional schools business
schools being one about leadership to
the extent that we begin to focus as
much on the kinds of relationship work
that needs to be done to effectively
move an organization towards its task or
its goal than just focusing on
individual skills and trade so I have
heard you say leadership is a role and
then you just said it's really a
relational concept can you sort of
describe how those two sort of
statements of what leadership is fit
together so I'll give you an example
when I sometimes work with groups of
executives or students and I'm being
slightly polemical and I say so you've
heard the phrase lead follow or get out
of the way yeah and and I say so that
suggests to you that you either lead or
you follow or in the worst case you make
yourself scarce and I say okay don't be
don't be shy or self-deprecating I need
you to choose which one of those you are
whether you're a leader or a follower
and everybody in the room gets very
nervous and they get sort of squeamish
and they don't particularly door a
follower and then I say to them okay I
won't make you choose let's say I asked
you how many people in this room are in
leadership roles and everybody's hand
goes up and then I say how many of you
are in followership roles and
everybody's hand goes up and then we
begin to see that the leadership and
followership are roles not traits or
characteristic of a person because the
vast majority of people I would say
actually a hundred percent of people who
work in organizations are in both roles
so role again means a set of activities
expected of somebody who inhabits a
certain place in an organization I would
say leadership is a role you have in
relationship to some people and in
to other people you are in a
followership role in relationship to
those people of the hierarchy
you